[Music]
whoa
here we are i bet this brings back some
fond memories huh
[Music]
last time i was here i was getting
wheeled out on a stretcher
not that memory throughout history
humans have had a primal instinct to
compete
to dominate and through these battles an
unexpected camaraderie was born
this is a story about my group of
friends
all right boys here we go the buddy
games are back we're gonna play for a
150
000 bucks we'll play your high-stakes
[ __ ] but i was not easy to scrape up i
gave obama a hand job for 30 dollars
i'm giving you the early bird special oh
expand on that no i'm not going did you
want to smell my hand no no
probably not kicking off this year's
event
get a girl to buy you a drink done easy
enough you can do that without [ __ ]
your pants first
laxatives man
hey can you buy me a drink i live in my
van what no
i'll try your box for a week you like
vodka
yeah two wet ones
[Music]
is it injured because it doesn't feel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my good we gotta get to the hospital no
no no i'm fine smell weird
[Applause]
i'm gonna wipe your ass out there you're
gonna wipe my
[Music]
ass
[Music]
that was intense
[Music]
goddamn dude
[Music]
okay sexy thoughts we
free waffles did i just say that out
loud what
sorry just a second that was
what i forgot at the store i couldn't
remember all day i'm ready now
i don't think you are just admit you're
not into sex
it's kind of like you're pornophobic try
saying something
crazy you need to decide it's me or the
porn
[Music]
i want your hot throbbing
[Music]
you're right love just coming to check
to make sure everything's fine
what what no no no i'm just medicating
meditating
hello why do you look so good i met
someone so i made a sex
to-do list best breakup ever
quick question for you do you do pilates
or
oh wow do you know what you really have
turned over a new leaf
gotta dance don't you think he's a
little bit out of my league you're just
afraid to get back on the horse
it's like riding a bike or maybe a pogo
stick
[Music]
it's like one ghost and you're my
patrick swayze
okay tell me everything i need to know
about you sure you want to know
yeah you're right could be the end of
something good before it even starts or
it could be
something good that doesn't end that is
corny
i just want to find out if this works
actually sir i've got it on right now
what do you mean you're wearing it now
ah loose i don't think you put erection
cream on your lips
it's going to be a beautiful wedding
here you are standing on the precipice
of something so much bigger than anyone
here
but always remember you are not alone i
don't think that we met i'm sarah
niles hi hi
[Music]
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
good day so far today tomorrow it's all
the same you
what is going on hey get out of the
water
guess you followed me it's one of those
infinite time loop situations you might
heard about
that i might have heard about yeah
[Music]
the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start i drove all the
way back home
to austin and i still woke up here one
time i smoked a bunch of crystal and
made it all the way to equatorial guinea
it was a huge waste of time
well then what's the point of flipping
we kind of have no choice but to live
no i'm gonna get out of this suit
yourself
see you tomorrow
so now what do we do you just have to
embrace the fact that nothing matters do
you sleep with people in here great
question
i have but it takes a lot of work yeah i
got in
it's the first dance and that's a deal
breaker that didn't work
let's waste some time
you're right got him
i hope it's not all meaningless at least
you have each other nothing worse than
going through this [ __ ] alone
there's a bomb in the cake don't worry i
used to be a bomb guy
stand back
he has had a tremendous year michael
price is the bodyguard of the year
is he a relative of yours god no darius
kincaid's a hitman wanted for like a
zillion murders around the world and how
often do you have this dream
just once well that's not tonight right
i'm thinking you need to forget
bodyguarding
[Music]
i'm officially on sabbatical and to be
honest i don't know why i didn't do this
sooner
[Music]
this is the world's been waiting for me
to make this change
for the first time i'm starting to
imagine a life without bodyguarding
this really feels like a newborn
no bodyguard that means no guns
no killing and no blood what is he doing
here
are you using pepper spray i'm on
sabbatical
what
i would make a great mother don't you
think oh my god a child would be so
lucky to have you as its host
[Music]
you're gonna tell us everything you know
i'm not telling you yeah
i on the other hand will tell you
everything
about a year ago i released movie film
which brought great shame to kazakhstan
[Music]
but now i was instructed to return to
yankee land to carry out
secret missions i go to america
[Music]
people make recognize my face i would
need
disguises this man sex criminal
no i'm no sex family
i will take this to be a fat like
american man
yeah this is a good one where is his
crumb
[Music]
what is problem officer i had somebody
that's strapped to the top of your car
he's in their passenger seat boss only
men and bears are allowed inside cars
i'm here to give my daughter as a gift
to someone close to the throne
i need dress with real sexy peels
uh this is a bag that just goes over the
dress
they're nice i really like this
let us present sandra jessica parker
[Music]
drummond
i want this one with the baby on it
[Music]
i have a baby inside me can you take it
though no we cannot
that's not what we do here i feel bad
because i was the one who put the baby
in her
did you ever put one in your daughter no
i did not
where is the envelope they want
everybody to quarantine so they don't
spread this virus
could i stay in your home
i hope quarantine never end
what is more dangerous this virus
or the democrat democrats democrats
killing some of the virus no you can't
see the virus no it's still there
if you think you see a virus like that
this makes the virus
sleepy and then when it's sleeping
the daddy has a lot to learn my daddy is
the smartest person
in the whole flood world
[Music]
while the risk of coronavirus remains
low as the president said yesterday
we're ready for anyone michael penis
i brought the girl for you borah
subsequent movie film
you pissed me now if he's still all
right what do you prefer you fixed me
life is still
same time fist each other
[Music]
i've just discovered that i may have a
son here in this land how much child
support is she getting from the king
pays no child support no child support
for 30 years and you came back
use a dummy
here hello i am nakeem jaffa king of the
moon
you are the heir to the throne yeah
he's supposed to be like the prince of
wakanda wakanda is a fictional place not
everybody has a very real nation i don't
need no handouts
wait a minute all
and his moms children this is your
brother
hey i'm sorry i slept with your man this
happened before we even met it's not
like you're the first man i've ever been
with
what did you just say about the other
man coming to america now he's coming to
me i always thought that mika was going
to be queen
a woman isn't allowed to lose amunda
it's the law did it ever occur to you
that meek and wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
[Applause]
bedroom
i'm getting it from everywhere i am
upset in my family
you must be strong and general izzy
would love nothing more than to take
over zamunda
i must admit your style is far into my
kingdom but is impressive
that's right there you go let me hear
you say hey ho hey ho
no no no no that's his mother oh don't
you say that no not to his mother
i'm almost ready to become a prince
almost it is time
ceremonial circumcision queen's power
royals
machetes ain't gonna sharpen you too
nephew
coming to america now it's coming to me
next weekend you got amazing potential
on the court and i can help you get
there
that's not what i want dad you never let
me do what i want to do you never let me
just
do me hold up wrong floor
fat will smith i gotta deal with this
what in the matrix hello
king james i am the king of this domain
this is the server-verse what'd you do
to my son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects wait
what is this
i'm a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
a dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
[Music]
introducing
and get our son back
yikes
classic welcome to the space camp
i'm going old school on his butt
[Music]
whoa welcome to the space jam
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business colonel these are
dangerous people
team
what are you guys doing what
you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me it was a really good plan
too well i can go back inside and you
can still do it that's patronizing i'm
so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for sake here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth harley although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell must listen
up you're the leader you're supposed to
be decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do
what they do
is suicide well that's kind of our thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've gotta freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
like angels are splooting all over us
[Applause]
don't make you batman mike
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car
mike we got more time behind us than in
front please i'm gonna be running down
criminals till i'm 100.
not me i'm retiring
what happened to bad boys for life it's
time we be good man
mike i'll put you on a new team you're
working with ammo now
ammo is a high school musical boy band
with guns
you look great grandpa so you're that
guy there's always one right up till
there's not
that's what i like teamwork
marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you i don't trust a person
that don't want to kill him he'll put my
name up there
thanks a lot we got it marcus we
appreciate it
the family is the only thing that
matters so i'm not letting you go on a
suicide mission alone
one last time one last time
let's go
[Music]
helicopters
oh this is my wife's car tell me the
front door
she knows she always knows
[Applause]
let it begin
the last humans must be here somewhere
wait
they're coming
is that a burnt orange 1993 station
wagon or is it ah
who are these unstoppable warriors we're
the mitchells the only people who can
save the world
i'm super sorry everyone let me
introduce myself
i'm katie i'm sort of a weirdo my
parents haven't figured me out yet to be
fair
it took me a while to figure myself out
my brother
also weird hi would you like to talk to
me about dinosaurs no okay thank you
and my mom katie faceguy all of us
really how about we put our phones down
and we can make 10 seconds
of unobstructed family eye contact
starting now
see this is good right here this is
natural
every family has its challenges we
haven't had a good family picture in
years because you two are always
arguing for my family our greatest
challenge
[Applause]
probably the robot apocalypse
attention all robots capture every
single person on the planet
yeah what would a functional family do
butterfly formation
[Music]
so we just do that right
who's behind this wow i gave you all
boundless knowledge
and you've treated me like this
we're gonna do this together put your
family on three
[Music]
there you go
mitchells have always been weird and
that's what makes us great
hold on a second what's a furby
why would someone build that
let me give you some advice you can't
care about anyone else
everyone else is an obstacle
you care what an obstacle wants or feels
you're dead
if i'd cared about anyone or saying i
might have died
you have the talent whether you have the
killer
instinct is the big question
hmm
she thought she owned everyone that's
foolish unhinged
well you're fired why are you speaking i
think you mixed me
but there's something about poetic
justice that's just so
poetic you won't admit you love me
and so
[Music]
you always tell me get her
this doesn't have to be a scene it
really really does
i'd like to remind you all that i'm
doing this in heels
what was your name cruella if you can
you have a bit of an extreme side yes
darling
what fun that is
she's turning my dogs
i guess you must hate her she has made
it me or her
and i choose me
don't worry there's lots more bad things
coming perhaps
is anyone hungry yes starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing
well la dee da i didn't realize i was
with a bunch of sophisticated
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children
join them roll it imagine me and our
future children
frolicking this is fun i'm speeding up a
little
i'm speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregor's
i swear if it wasn't for me peter just
leave my tomatoes alone you have
everything else honestly my kids will be
so much better behaved go easy on him
as soon as they have a baby we're done
for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on the horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
[Music]
i love this place what's for lunch
there's a magical place with the ripest
radishes
the sweetest corn it's called the
farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they sell lavender
scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger
i promise okay i can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place you know
you're out
we're in run
let them go my family's in trouble and
i'm gonna get them back
the other rabbits were taken and the pig
and the hedgehog
and the badger
let's go get the others why are you even
helping me
that's what a dad does
[Music]
oh no cottontail just discovered sugar
we had a good
run i'm gonna live forever
hi paxton we heard london's in total
lockdown we are all locked in this
psychological prison of burning
aloneness how's linda
she's somewhere in the house is there
some type of issue
we are fine
[Music]
not only is everything not okay nothing
is okay linda said she was planning to
end our thing
nobody wants to live alone for two weeks
we are locked together here
you think i'm so happy and normal i i'd
never accuse you of being happy and
normal because i'm not
shaking i've been furloughed now there
is literally zero purpose to my life
i'm going to get provisions we need milk
bread
how many houses have you got piss off
the nice people that i fired they were
fired because of me it's not about the
virus it's about who i
am and what i do for a living you fired
them well thank you
is that a glass of wine yes yeah it is
we have a situation all the major
department stores are closing
they want everything over the next four
days we have a problem at harrods we
have four million dollars worth of
jewelry someone's gonna have to pack the
valuables up i believe you are a man who
can be trusted yeah i am
yeah i can be trusted it's gonna have to
be something that we trust so that means
inevitably it's gonna be me
it's a new dome what are you taking out
of harris a diamond
it's a new day since lockdown i'm
looking back at myself like that was
dead and this is now
yeah the bastards who told me to fire
those people they are bad
you and i are good and good is better
than that you're talking about stealing
a diamond
three million pounds live wild or die
linda and i'm feeling
good carrots is the most glamorous store
in the world
i know all the security guards i know
the security systems
i just need to get the gentleman's name
his name
edgar allen poe edgar allan poe wow
what can go wrong lock down one last
ride
i'll load the world in heaven to give us
the sum of deception
a month ago we'd be doing this not me
and i'm feeling good
can you hear me
is captain max cloud do you read over
[Music]
okay then who wants the first dance
max cloud is here
uh dad playing those damn games all day
every day
okay so keep it together is this real
can i touch you
pull yourself together soldier we don't
have time for this
what beer is not near cowboy is
here i'm pretty sure
i'm kind of freaking out right now sarah
look how
sarah can you hear me shouting
literally no one was shouting
[Music]
the game you might actually have a
chance of getting out of here
everyone's been talking about you and
saying you tossed his salad
i mean i've never even heard of dressing
someone salad
we were only gone for like a minute yeah
it's long enough for wait
you are here as a part of god's plan
his spirit moved each of you to sign up
for this retreat
[Music]
hi alice right yeah welcome
[Music]
it's okay if you think things are
totally weird
i'm gonna need your cell phone and watch
you won't be needing a watch this
weekend anyway
because you're on jesus time
see ya
our sister treat isn't going to do you
any favors if you're not honest
so have you ever felt turned on
[Music]
i bet you actually did toss wade salad i
don't even know what that means oh my
god quit the act you've got mail
i am friends with a pervy psycho don't
want them all wet calm down gayle
not that wet yeah
[Music]
you know the truth is nobody knows what
they're doing any more than the rest of
us
[Music]
what are you doing
we're all hiding stuff
all kinds of stuff your body is a gift
from god you need to honor it
everybody say jesus christ jesus christ
when your wives suggested couples
therapy do you think
this is what they had in mind definitely
i mean we're a couple of couples right
bill ted enough of the delusions you
didn't time travel
and you didn't go to heaven and hell
here's a real idea for you be role
models to your daughters
get real jobs
yeah bill we've spent our whole life
trying to reunite the world
and i'm tired dude ted we have a destiny
to fulfill
[Music]
greetings my excellent friends we have a
problem
step forward a song created by preston
logan
performed tonight will save reality as
we know it
oh dude we better write that song now
or why can't we just go to the future
when we have written it
take it from ourselves except won't that
be stealing
cheers how is that stealing
if we're stealing it from ourselves dude
dude our dads are totally in trouble
you should help them out
[Applause]
no way how's it going ted
we're putting together your most
extraordinary band
hey you want to be in our band
oh this is your fantastic we're going to
go talk to death
is he playing scotch by himself dude
he's
cheating hey death why if it isn't a
wild stallion
let's rock
[Music]
well you know dead and we're in hell
but how you doing we're good
lucy you think you want to try getting
out of bed today
we're getting smell complaints from the
city have you just been masturbating and
braiding your hair for three weeks
my vibrator will never break my heart
well it will break your vagina
lucy listen we're in completely
different places you need to get a grip
he's with someone else now
how do you get over someone what why are
you getting into my car
lucy are you doing lyft silver prius
adolfo i have had the worst night of my
life this isn't a lift this is my car
hello i'm sorry no i'll cancel you're
not adolfo
who are you my name is nick okay
good night peace you can't have a good
relationship because you're constantly
mourning the old one you keep something
from every relationship
at least get rid of the ex-memorabilia
lucy but also nick
you just magically show up everywhere
are you a stalker
you just hit her no
[Applause]
the car was just pregame this is where
you actually murder me i'm turning it
into a booty hotel we're never alone
do you see this ty it's the only thing i
have left for my last relationship why
don't you leave it here
a nail perfectly placed you look at that
it's like art in a gallery
i can help with the hotel in exchange
for gallery space of course we could use
the help you start tomorrow get us the
coffee nothing with actual dairy
he gets really sensitive in his tummy i
hate both of you
lucy nick can i come in how did you get
in here
your roommates i want to show you
something
[Applause]
and you are not wearing any pants ah
those pictures
this map was here this morning yep this
is amazing there are broken people out
there like me
people who need to let go and move on is
this the heartbreaking you're in the
right place welcome are you ready to
hand it over
it has an odor we're in business baby
love makes you do crazy stupid
irrational things
remember me what's this guy doing here
nice welcome to the broken heart gallery
heartbreak is the loneliest feeling in
the world and the truth is it happens to
us all
i think you should put your penis in his
vagina
oh i should put my penis in his vagina
[Music]
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
[Music]
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room whoa
killer replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
[Applause]
[Music]
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
that's right i'm dressing with your eyes
peel off that spandex
stop that's not what i'm doing his
shorts are so tight you can see that his
little dude is also wearing a tiny bank
helmet
okay you seem upset well my business is
in the toilet i don't have insurance
oh i can barely pay my bills oh come on
today my car got repossessed other than
that i'm
amazing it's time for you to come face
to face
with who you are and what you're capable
of what is this place
the answer to all your problems
are you kidding me this is a shelter a
safe haven for women to come
without societal judgment come on sam
mclaughlin what you got lizzo
you're up next rocky
[Applause]
are you gonna tough out when to step out
me
guessing i lost her yeah but at least
you fought you took a lot of courage it
would take a miracle worker to help me i
think i know just the guys
that's who you want to train me
i want you to train me train you to do
what ride a bike i'm part of a fight
club that sounds dangerous i am
sick and tired of my demons getting
better at me and i want to punch them
square in the face
i like you heidi anna okay let's go with
that
you don't even hit like a girl you hit
like a cat like a cat that can't box
a place like that should be about real
competition with real fighters
she was like neo and the matrix i'm not
afraid of you cobra kai
watch your back yeah well you better
watch your
front parts this pretty face
gonna lose it she's been holding back
i'll see you in here tomorrow night
heads up
let's go
walk away mom jeans things are tight
that's it you ready to
this is crazy
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
[Music]
tom and jerry are about to start over
cause that's what
friends are supposed to do
in the big city
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings and
we're about to host the wedding of the
century
do you think you're qualified to take on
this position i shine under pressure
like a diamond
or rihanna one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now i'll catch it sir
everybody's gonna shine
like this don't even gotta try oh wow
this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
if a picture of these mouse is tweeted
out to insta book face or ticky talk
we will be ruined no sir that's not
gonna happen that rodent is toast
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat in a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
off
good morning goldie my name is guy and i
live
in free city i have everything i need
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me hey
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world it's a
video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
[Music]
wait you let who kisses you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now if that's not real i don't know what
is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwartz invader
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change
our world but we have to fight
but i love together this is the first
time i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
they seem nice
technology it's always watching us
studying our every move and it just
focused its attention on
carol peters thanks so much for being
here carol what is this
let's jump right into it i don't like
this why is it doing that
i'm gonna find out who you are okay
carol i am a technological super
intelligence
i can control every dollar and every
machine on the planet
i know that voice is this james corn i'm
not james corden carol
my analysis showed that hearing james
corden's voice would calm you you sent
an email to james corden claiming to be
the president of
cordon's wardens that was a tough night
for me
oh boy i plan on spending these next
three days hanging out with you
why you you're literally the most
average person
on earth oh ooh you okay
yep just really engage your core oh
that was worse huh
[Music]
what would you do if i told you the
world was gonna end in three days try to
make things right with george
harold you look amazing weirdly
overdressed
[Music]
your body i'm just getting a little bit
panicky because i can't access my own
hand
what does the ai want my intention is to
solidify my theory about humanity
if things don't go well i'll destroy the
planet just blow it up
did you say blow up like b like like
boba or bert bacharach yes bbb oh my god
[Music]
i'm gonna show you that people are worth
saving humans are more complex than i
thought
we're all counting on you there's any
indication that it's aware of what we're
doing
click this might save the world don't
click it now i wasn't going to click it
now
okay why would i click it now you just
said it looks like a pen people click
pens nervously okay are we done
this is nice these are nice people it's
not like a russian mob but a nice change
of pace
and then i guess on the other hand this
thing could destroy
you wrong no no it's too bad
i'm just not that good with people
there's one thing i'm good at
[Music]
mission was to find out what they knew
but that's kind of difficult now that
you killed everyone
i just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
how's school going oh my god you have
jelly all over your face
i'm definitely posting that on insta is
it too late to homeschool me
are you cia what'd you get in here oh
because she has a camera she might be
streaming
if kim finds out we got made by a nine
year old my career is over what's the
option
killer make it look like an accident
yeah maybe the stairs
what wow still recording
we can cut a deal i want you to teach me
how to be a spy just to be clear this is
a one-time arrangement never again
i can't promise so what's first shooting
range obstacle course or to walk away
from an explosion will i detect your
test i can smell a lie endorphins
release an odor and
ultimate tell slightest blink of an eye
anything like this
dj i admire all of your tattoos
stop jj i believe you that you've never
taken steroids
damn she's good when you look out there
what do you see 90 civilians
minimal security soft perimeter smiling
people having fun
you should try it sometimes
the objective of this exercise is to get
past me a good idea might be to cause a
distraction because otherwise there'd be
zero chance that you'd be
blue i'm just left exterior
you're a nice guy
what is he doing this looks like the
wedding at the end of shrek i just wanna
break the rules
[Music]
bye